joining me now is Miranda Devine New
York Post columnist Fox News contributor
Miranda what more can you tell us about
this deposition and more importantly why
does it matter in the context of
Hunter's additional legal troubles
look I think the significance of this
Laura is that this is the first time
that Hunter Biden has to swear give
testimony under oath about the laptop
and it seems that he gave contradictory
and very conflicting and confusing
testimony you know he refused to admit
that the laptop was his yet he was
saying that he's in his privacy had been
invaded and that the content was
embarrassing to him
um he refused to admit that he had been
to John Paul Mac Isaac's Wilmington
computer repair shop twice in April of
2019 despite the fact that his signature
is on the work order his contact details
are all correct that he gave to John
Paul Mac Isaac he doesn't have any
explanation for how these things
miraculously happened
um and Miranda throughout he yeah
well I mean look I I think it's obvious
throughout he just denied obfuscated
said he couldn't remember uh you know
he's I think relying on the fact of his
very famous drug use which he wrote a
book about to try and get out of this uh
the reality all right Miranda The Daily
Mail is reporting that Hunter was
talking with his father's best friend
Ted Kaufman just three days
before he joined that Barista board in
April 2014 Hunter emailed Kaufman who'd
recently visited Ukraine asking for his
prediction of the country's upcoming
elections Miranda quickly what does that
tell you
well Ted Kaufman is sort of like the
Svengali behind Joe Biden he's been a
loyal factotum for him his chief of
staff and even sat in for him in his
senate seat for a while
um he's a shadowy character travels to
Ukraine uh seems to know a lot about
that country and certainly was a mentor
for Hunter before he joined barisma well
could he be a conduit from Joe to Ted to
Hunter so you could Joe can say I didn't
talk to my son about this but maybe he
did through this individual
100 I mean dead Ted Kaufman and Joe
Biden there's nothing between them you
know they are joined at the hip yeah
Miranda thank you so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else